bon alors on a demandé aux gens ce
qu'ils pensaient de toi dans la rue et
c'est pas terrible
c'était mon quartier enfin c'était j'ai
repris du terrain à montparnasse
voilà je suis très content que je suis
sorti en chef terre on va regarder
comédienne vous intéresse ou pas
pourquoi ouais c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment hors circuit qui se maintient
pas comme elle peut mais bon je n'ai pas
d'antipathie particulière pour elle mais
vite sympathie physiquement vous la
trouvez comment
mais cette fois physique j'apprécie
beaucoup
elle est plus côté à l'argus elle est
allée voir sa prochaine pièce sexy
physiquement pas du tout loin de là
la trouvez comment je pense qu'elle est
plus lente ou rapide un flop il fallait
agir est bien là pas faire du premier là
je peux pas croire que j'en dise à toi
mon avis je sais pas il ya anguille sous
roche
as tu crois tu penses que c'est de là
que je pense que c'est de l'intox peu
petit mais shotton commun
on va voir alors on va voir sur qui
portait la question et pensez-vous de
line renaud la lune rhône au monsieur
que pensez vous de l'humour no comment
que pensez-vous de line renaud ont pu
parler avec mes camarades y en avait
quand même les couettes sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus